foreign
why well because we have your own power
speaking soon
it's right now you can see the bottom
right into the screen the current time
when I'm filming this video right now is
a half one UTC time and in another and a
half that's going to be at three o'clock
P.M in UTC time we're gonna have to run
power speaking
we've heard different fomc officers
speaking this week we've had Bullard
Jefferson bar
we had I think seven or eight but most
of them agree and are saying the same
most of them are saying the inflation is
still a problem that is not coming down
as fast as they want to
dice is sticky and they are not very
sure if they see to stop
raising interest rates they are dropping
the clue that maybe they should continue
hiking okay so that's why
the market might be a bit concerned
about what your own power says because
he's the boss so
um be very careful trading during three
o'clock UTC time
I personally recommend you to not have
any positions open at that time okay
because the market is going to react to
his words and if he says something
regarding the next fomc meeting
then the market is going to react okay
now if you check the chart you can see
that we've had a choppy price action you
know we've seen you know the weekend
range Mondays for smooth then we seen a
retrace then on Wednesday price went up
we saw a bar Simpson here yesterday
we're going to talk about this in a
moment price dropped
another recovery you can see it's
ranging okay we're still in the same
price as in the weekend range
okay this is your weekend range over
here if you extend it
we are still in the weekend range so
nothing has happened just you know
choppy up down up down but still in the
same range okay why that's because the
market is you know waiting for news
announcements if we go to the SMP we're
gonna talk in a moment about the dead
ceiling
you can see the price
is pumping now okay we've been in the
let's go to the Daily time frame we'll
be in this range
since the first week of April so that's
been a month and a half
and yesterday we came out of this range
over here
why because they are
talking now about the debt ceiling and
we could expect without some of the
markets is expecting that there is a
boat next week
to increase the debt ceiling okay so
that's why probably the SMP has you know
poomed from here because he just needed
some news announcements that's what the
market is doing waiting for his
announcements and reacting to them
all right but that's a different story
let's go to bitcoin again
what is bitcoin
okay if you go to the one or time frame
yesterday
where we were in this point here okay
and I was telling you this is so simple
we have the one hour 50ma here so you
know if we can hold above it and you see
some kind of you know different test of
support then you could imagine price
going up all the way to 27 800 but if it
fails to test that support
like you did
then it's as simple as you know the the
moment that you see loosen and closing
below it so that will be here go short
and you are gonna Target these liquidity
pools over here okay so this would be
your first liquidity pool you have
another one here and of course this one
and you can see that in one simple
candle okay they hit all the liquidity
pools
so that's what we're talking about and
now you can see that you know this large
scandal for the guys that have been
watching all the YouTube videos
and the guys that have joined the course
they know what this is okay if this is
called
a liquidity pool this is an imbalance
okay this large red candle and you can
see here
how
they they filled the imbalance
almost to the roller check this out okay
was that week that week is literally you
know
almost to the dollar like literally how
many dollars differences is two or three
dollars difference to the liquidity pool
okay and now you can see the water is
still below the 150 MMA as in the market
is when I wait
until Jerome power starts to speak and
again it's very simple
if you don't Powell
is Hawkeyes then we might see price
coming all the way down again
and if he's dovish then we would expect
a push
retest the 50ma and push again to this
one over here okay it's as simple as
that if you go to the four hour time
frame this even more interesting you can
see that we have a new week okay I've
told you guys I'm not happy until they
feel this week so until they feel this
week I'm gonna keep telling you there is
a week here there is an imbalance the
price needs to come back to okay but now
we have the problem but there is a new
week here because this week is uh uh
we're talking about 400 dollars a week
okay so yes that's an interesting week
for now the most logical thing is to
wait you know until 3 o'clock UTC time
I'm going to watch the speech of your
own power I'm gonna see what he says
because I want to uh problem when I
write a threat about what the different
fomc officers have said this week and
what Jerome Powell said today
because they've been giving us some
clues about economic Outlook but uh yes
as a Trader today what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna wait
and then I'm gonna try to trade the
imbalances okay
that's basically what I'm planning to do
today so
just be careful you also know that we're
gonna have the weekend again from
tomorrow because today is Friday as you
might see again something like this you
know we can range
here quite choppy okay so the most
likely thing is that today we might
manage to get
uh one or two scalps maximum I'm
expecting more than that because we are
gonna start to trade
um
from three well I don't know how long
he's gonna be speaking for maybe 30
minutes or an hour we'll see but we're
gonna start trading maybe from half
three or four so I don't know how much
the market can move after he says maybe
he doesn't say anything really
interesting okay so I don't know why I'm
going to be facing today I know I'm
gonna be waiting I'm gonna see if we see
some imbalances in the chart and then
trade them and if you go to the volatile
index
because the dollar Index is moving
remember guys the you know we've been
talking about this W pattern for quite
some time
uh it seems like it might be playing out
now and if we go into lower time frame
you can see that is test what he has
tested the one hour 50ma and it's
bouncing again that happened here it
happened here okay
so if we see another bounce here
towards a hundred
three and a half then Bitcoin would
continue going down but
in the other hand if you go to the four
hour time frame
just looking a bit of an extended isn't
it because you can see 94 time frame we
haven't really you know
tested the 4r50ma so if we start to see
some kind of sideways move for the
dollar Index here then that'll give time
the 50ma to catch up with this okay
maybe something like this
and that's when we could see maybe a
doom in the dollar Index but that would
be for next week okay test the 450ma and
if he holds it then yes you can see
continuation to the upside so that's
what I mean guys uh at the moment
everything is looking a bit choppy I'm
not gonna lie to you uh today doesn't
look a good day
for trading and I'm quite honest with
you with how I see the days and I
usually tell you this week looks good
for the trading sessions or for the
weekly psychological pattern or this
week is only good for scalps because we
have a lot of
news coming out
um I'll tell you today's should be
the most difficult day of the week to
trade or that's what I'm anticipating I
would like to see a rejection I'm not
gonna lie to you I would like to see a
rejection in Bitcoin in either in the 1
or 50ma or even more ideally in the 4
out of 50 I mean okay that's what I
would like to see
now we know that there is a lot of
liquidity here okay in this area we're
here there is still a lot of liquidity
because if we check this that's around
the daily 50ma that was supporting all
this time okay so there is a lot of
liquidity here because we have the 50
The Daily 50ma Audio wanna see some
limit orders but also remember that
yesterday we went through the
liquidation heat map in high block and
at 27 800 there is quite of liquidity
okay I'm not favoring that zone yet the
only way I'm gonna favor this one
attracting 2000 is if we see a pump here
okay
retrace and Thursday 4r50ma and then yes
you can see a pump towards this Zone but
for now you know we failed to test the
450ms support here
again here
uh why not why couldn't we see a pump
here and then another retrace
all level to 26k
so anyway guys be very careful with your
trades today might be quite a complex
day for trading also if you have time
watch your own powers the speed because
it might be interesting or that's at
least what I'm hoping for I don't want
to get bored like last time in the FMC
press conference house that was horrible
and thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon